among the roofs in Copenhagen is a kind
of oasis a unique garden located in the
heart of Denmark's capital it was built
on a connecting roof of three penthouses
in a 150 year old building architect yes
person / came up with the idea hello
welcome come on in this impact lives
with his wife and two sons in one of the
100 square meters of penthouses
before we see the apartment I think we
should go and check out the roof garden
the communal roof garden serves as an
alternative to a backyard for the
building's residents three terraces are
spread over 450 square meters official
permission took six years because
buildings are only allowed to have five
floors in Copenhagen and the addition of
the penthouses a garden made seven
really a nice way that you could just no
just go up here for five minutes enjoy
the view some of my neighbors they they
go up here and read the morning paper
before they go to work and it's just you
don't have to do that every day but just
the that you're able to do that it's
really something it's a luxurious
feeling I would say the penthouse
windows let in lots of light
this enhances the simplicity of the
scandinavian interior design one of the
main qualities I think about this place
and this apartment is is the the is the
light the daylight and the view you have
of the sky that you constantly you can
follow the way that the weather changes
in the delight and then the clouds and
so on changes during the day the central
living and dining area leads onto a
bedroom a bathroom and two children's
rooms when furnishing the apartment sim
bag and his wife wanted each piece to
tell its own story this lamp is actually
an old street lamp come hiking street
lamp which they have been using all over
Copenhagen for many years and they're
changing them now into a more modern
kind of lab and so they sell some of
them to use as interior lamps moving
here man major downsizing for the sin
back family but for them the size is
secondary
for us this is the perfect place to live
it's a really nice neighborhood and then
of course with the this apartment and
the roof garden and so on which is
something we've fought for and been
working hard on for many years it's it's
not something you want to give up this
uniquely landscaped penthouse and
Copenhagen is a testament to what can be
achieved with limited space in the
middle of the city